could the Kevin Costner era of
Yellowstone be coming to an end welcome
everybody to Entertainment Tonight talk
about a plot twist Say It Ain't So this
show literally exploded out of the gate
back in 2018 and it went on to become
TV's number one show here are the latest
details on all the wild Dutton drama
I'm going to end it if it doesn't end
but I'll go tell I'm not interested
I'll go chill it it doesn't feel like um
we're interesting
the report Costner wants out yes even
though he makes a reported 1.3 million
per episode rumor is he wants to spend
Just One Week shooting season 5's
remaining episodes scheduled to air this
summer the idea of you know where it's
gone you don't predict that kind of
thing the
work allegedly denied Costner's request
sending the show into a tail spin but
here's what we know E.T has learned
production hasn't started because the
last half of season five is still being
written the TV news no doubt a surprise
to many including the cast I can tell
you there'll be six and there'll be a
seven so that's all I can tell you
yes sources tell ET many staffers were
blindsided leading to tensions and
confusion amongst the cast and crew
including showrunner Taylor Sheridan
who's had a plan for this series since
the start Taylor knows How It Ends and
he's told me that he's so far ahead of
us you know he had the Bible from season
one about how this was Gonna Roll when
will you know it's time I mean
you know it time's coming and it's
coming unfortunately the story needs to
end a little before everybody wants it
to Matthew McConaughey's reportedly in
negotiations for a Yellowstone extension
series which makes sense given the Texas
native star power and many
cowboy-inspired roles not a soul in this
County isn't sick to death of your book
it's not gonna be a free ticket
Paramount reps tell ET Matthew is a
phenomenal Talent with whom we'd love to
partner but what's the real reason
behind Costner's possible early exit you
should think twice I thought plenty
about it directing from last August to
November he's been at the helm of his
own Civil War epic Horizon Kevin also
Stars alongside his 13 year old son
Hayes and he plans to make it a
four-part franchise part two is slated
to start shooting in the spring I have
other things that I will
want to do directing producing and
starring it is awesome it's a bunch
[Music]